so how does like new york as a big city
compared to tokyo always living there
it's like
tokyo is amazing yeah i actually i love
it here that's good it's literally
new york
but clean
you're
yeah
[Laughter]
well new york has the the grid system
which is like it gets boring because you
just what straight lines right yeah yeah
japan has just like get straight lines
and then
yeah like lots of little like that's
that's it that's all you know i mean no
food differences in a restaurant oh oh
my god dude
you're looking at it in the eyes of like
an architect
i'm like straight lines
japan everyone
i like i like i like lost like 20 pounds
before getting here yeah obviously not
my goal right
which i hate but anyways i'm trying to
[ __ ] lose weight here in japan
impossible there's like every you go
down one street yeah food food food food
go to the next next one food food food
food yeah food food food snack snack
snack snack it's impossible and it's all
carbs and i'm just like i can't i can't
like control myself like and then you
have a beer
and then you have a beer and then you
have a beer which is cheap because in if
you want to buy a beer normally if you
go to the bar you have to tip the
bartender yeah yeah yeah
and then the beer costs like eight
dollars so it's like nine dollar a beer
it's like over here it's like what like
three bucks yeah no tips yeah yeah yeah
i've been to some izakayas where it's 50
yen a beer oh okay wow wow
yeah yeah that's right so that's why i
noticed they have like low carb beer too
which is i shot the green label i showed
him the uh the green stuff why would you
do that why would you do that it's good
because he was he was constantly
complaining about carbs and stuff and i
was like
i was like daddy says [ __ ] taste he'll
probably like this beer yeah
[Laughter]
it's literally like water it doesn't
taste like beer
yeah yeah i like water
i'm not
i'm not i'm not
but it's like it's like do you like bud
light
it's water a can is like 100 calories
and like no carbs yeah it's pretty you
know if you're on a diet it's pretty
friendly well the thing in america right
now
in america right now is very popular
it's the um heart seltzer yeah what's
that i thought it was not the salts of
water
seltzer
water but like they put alcohol in it or
salsa water
like just isn't it carbonated water
carbonated oh so it's like white claw is
that is that it
i guess i guess supposedly
well white cloth puts a little bit of
flavoring in it okay so they've removed
the foam
they've removed the fun from white claw
which already wasn't fun originally it
has it depends on which salsa you want
but yeah white claw is the most popular
one okay okay okay
but they put alcohol in it they do
like five to six eight percent or
something oh so it's like a strong zero
basic
water stream no no no it's it's it's
basically just yeah alcohol water or
something right it's it's you hand
sanitizer
what lengths have we gone to like the
normal
sparkling sparkling normally they call
sparkling when it's like it has flavor
enhanced really does it i don't think
yeah like aspartame or whatever it's
called what's the other one there's a
bunch of other brands like some perrier
or whatever area that's that's sparkling
water
exactly but that's what sparkling water
is
that's what's different from salsa well
then well
like unflavored though and then like
sparkling's like here's a cherry flavor
oh yeah yeah i guess so do you find that
japan is giving you any inspiration for
this yeah yes yeah super motivation
yeah because when i made you know when i
did youtube as a job back yeah in yeah
united states or maine or whatever my
mom's basement basically yeah yeah i
didn't really have like any reason to
make money i was just like when i did
make money i was like
all right but like i never i never had a
use for it
because i don't i didn't pay for my food
my mom was like yeah yeah but then like
my mom was like
you should move out but she's also very
sad about it too yeah yeah yeah i'm like
oh man i'm like conflicted but then i'm
like
i gotta move out like i have to like
mentally yeah yeah yeah i was rotting
down there yeah yeah yeah um especially
when i think i wanted to move out when
before covert hit and then hit and i was
like yeah well i just be a basement
dwell again right right right i eat
domino's pizza and did you always plan
to move to japan or was it just like the
opportunity came and you're like all
right this is it this is what i've been
waiting for i'll take anything
i mean if
the opportunity to rise officers yeah
okay yeah i mean yeah yeah you got an
opportunity that like a lot of people
would kill for yeah yeah i mean like uh
i'm a weeb
right
we know
yeah yeah yeah it's just really weird
going to the cobini and like seeing like
detective conan and i'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll go on the
train and i'll see like gotcha
advertisements or like yeah yeah nice
anime art and i'm like this is crazy i
was like
it was pretty wild because i'm so sad
because like i missed out on the like
because i wasn't in tokyo when you like
were here yeah we gotta hang out yeah
yeah yeah of course well like i i missed
out on like the initial like yeah yeah
japan like saga that happened well i'm
still like every time i go to a conbinis
store i'm still like what is this what
is that
it's like there's so many things you
know yeah
cause i love seeing reactions to like
people who come to japan for the first
time yeah yeah
like everything right because i remember
my first reaction like seeing a [ __ ]
combini and just like yeah the beanie's
like the funnest one
yeah
it is it is i've gone to the conbini
i've seen japan
like [ __ ] akihabara it's all about the
combinations
what are you eating i'm like i like 7 11
the best yeah what are you eating though
oh i'm not like everything all no not
everything just whatever
i'm trying to stay healthy right so yeah
yeah you had the cup ramen yet no it's
pretty good
just try it
did you not hear what you just said he's
trying to lose weight
try it
try it
curry flavor just a little curry flavor
i notice they they they only have like
the the tin cans or whatever not the tin
cans the plastic cups right the plastic
america they got the the little little
bag oh like the like the packet ramen
yeah they have they they have it here
it's just like everyone likes the
kids
wait what do you mean the cups are
everywhere everywhere yeah sorry i meant
the package the package no the package
[ __ ] you probably need to go to like a
supermarket yeah that's they sell them
at the supermarket you want the packet
[ __ ] so you can eat it at home it tastes
better no it's no yeah if you deck it
you get to take it yourself oh what oh
[ __ ] no why don't just make a cup ramen
and then just like empty it out into a
plate it would not [ __ ] love the
curry
dude that [ __ ] the curry wanted
does it matter
i [ __ ] love the dough i i think
i think i think they all taste the same
right
right
oh this is another all bread tastes the
same thing no no it's it's flavors taste
very different gone it's like there's a
curry there's a curry one that's really
good and then there's like a tomato one
that's yeah good there's a seafood one
that's really good
for your taste buds no no i'm i'm saying
if like if you if there's cup ramen in a
cup and cup and ramen in the packet
that's the same flavor they both taste
the same oh i thought you were saying
the curry and the tomato was tasting oh
right no i was just i was just like
because he was talking about the packet
because they taste better they taste the
same yeah yeah they taste like yeah i'm
just like
the best sauce the one with the cup
they've given you literally like the
perfect measurement of water to put in
yeah in a bowl i always overdo it under
to it you know
you gotta get good right now you gotta
that's that's that that just means you
haven't cooked enough ramen out of a
bowl you i i know those i like the cup
noodles way more and also dude this
sounds like you're just about here you
don't wanna oh no no no
half of the experience is [ __ ]
holding it and just like [ __ ] going
no it's hot burns your head
put it in the bowl
why are you holding it while you're
pouring the hot water in
sometimes the heat goes through the
styrofoam and you're like
what are you what am i the only one here
please joey i mean i've never had that i
don't know how sensitive the nerves on
your fingers yeah yeah
i know because like with someone
depending on like the packet or flavor
of the ramen i i think it like requires
a different amount of water for like the
optimal
taste yeah in my opinion yeah some some
some sauces are a bit thicker some
sauces are a bit thicker you like it was
watery i like it like thick man i like i
like it concentrated i like it watery
so but that's the thing well like the
cup ramen right they have like a like a
lion on the inside which is like this is
the one so if you like yours water you
just pour a little more water than the
line yeah yeah yeah you poured a little
bit on them yeah it's like perfectly
measured out for you yeah yeah so
there's no like you know gambling in a
[ __ ] sound like a cup ramen culture i
just like i don't like it
is [ __ ] awesome i mean it's good i
mean i i trash it is good i just prefer
the package it was invented by americans
dude like you're talking a little too
about [ __ ] yeah oh cool yeah
it actually was actually it was invented
by the americans learned that the
cup noodles the museum right museum yeah
the cup ramen museum
museum and then you'll change your mind
i think someone went there before
i think people have gone there
yeah yeah okay
people have gone there before i think
i think two of them are in this room
right now i think emily went to it i
think oh really i think there's one in
california that's why
oh really oh